anthropogenic climate change may be
novel but from planet Earth's point of
view over deep time there is nothing new
Under the Sun when Stanford scientists
recently announced in the New York Times
no less the arrival of zombie
Forest I had to roll my eyes that's
taking it too far we shouldn't need to
sensationalize science for a fast new
cycle a zombie is a mythological Undead
corporeal Revenant that moves and eats
human
flesh that's a bizarre descriptor for
communities of rooted photosynthetic
organisms that are living out of time so
to speak in their climate space
ecologists would call this a large scale
selection event and a vegetative type
conversion in process it's sad news for
Ponderosa Pines or really for the people
who love Ponderosa Pines it's bad news
for the Golden State's greenhouse gas
sequestration C
calulations but from an evolutionary
point of view it's good news for
chapparel
species